The Joe Rogan Experience
comedians don't and really can't
exercise political power they might you
know influence to a certain extent the
way that people think about certain
things but
um nobody's you know nobody who's who's
doing comedy is uh is making decisions
you know that directly uh directly
impact uh people's lives so so if if you
were actually trying
to to do that you know like if you're
actually trying to affect real change
this doesn't make any sense what I think
it is is it's a symptom of how extreme
this kind of moralistic approach to
politics can get right that like you're
this concerned with like constantly you
know testing you know whether somebody
is a is a good person or a bad person or
they ever said anything that you know
that might show them to like to really
be a bad person and nothing could ever
just be a bad moment right that you know
that that it has to be like this is the
moment where you really revealed the you
know how toxic your soul was or
something you know rather than just like
you said something stupid because
sometimes people say things that are
stupid you know that uh like I think
that that kind of moralism when it's
applied to Comedy I think that that's I
think that that's like maybe the most
extreme symptom of of what I'm talking
about because it's one thing even to get
mad at somebody because like of
something they wrote like in an
editorial right that they're they're
telling you like exactly what the thing
should happen you know that like if I
you know if I write you know if I write
something for Jacobin and you know some
people get upset about that okay at
least it's a jack of an article I'm
literally saying exactly what I think
right but
if you're doing you know a um account
like so so that last uh Dave Chappelle
special at Netflix you know that that
people people got mad about and which by
the way I I you know hadn't even watched
but since I'd written this thing you
know people kept asking me what I
thought and I finally watched it and I
thought that the way that it was
portrayed as if it were this like just
Festival of transphobic you know hatred
preposterone it was ridiculous that in
fact the overall theme of the special as
far as those issues go was about him
like moving towards a place of Greater
understanding and you know and and like
and it's also kind of a love letter to
his friend that committed suicide for
supporting him was attacked for
supporting him and then she jumped off a
[ __ ] building and committed suicide
this is like in an homage to this
person's life this long part of like I
worked with Dave during the entire time
he was piecing that together because we
started doing shows in Austin like uh
November of 2020. it might have even
been earlier than that and we were
working together while he was putting it
together and he was responding to this
idea that he was transphobic and he was
saying like this is so crazy like this
is who I am and this is about this
person who when I was accused of being
transphobic this person defended me and
was dragged by people and there's been
some talk of whether or not like how
much of that was creative license
because like people have tried to find
like what the tweets were how many of
them were DMs like we don't know I mean
I don't think you could dismiss that or
how many of them or people who actually
knew her personally but then committed
suicide and like this is like trying to
make it's the highest form of comedy in
a lot of ways because you're trying to
take this like socially sensitive issue
and extract laughs from it which is very
difficult to do but in no way was it
transphobic in no way was it hurtful or
cruel or or mean well I mean I mean
actually he's like he spent a couple
minutes the special explaining why the
bathroom was North Carolina were cruel
and like at the end like when he's
talking about his dead friends like one
of the crucial moments comes when he's
describing they're like back and forth
you know when he he had her open for him
and yeah and it's hilarious yeah which
is a hilarious thing but there is this
like really moving part of it right at
the at the end where you know he you
know she's she tells him you know like
I want you to recognize that I'm going
through a real human experience yeah I
can and like it really sinks in in that
and the idea that watching this would
make somebody more transphobic yeah just
just seems absurd to me but what people
did right is they literally quoted
individual sentences that he says in it
like like there's one point in the
special where he says uh I'm a Turf
right Turf standing for Trans extension
Turf yeah radical yeah and it's like
okay but
literally within like two minutes of him
saying I'm on team Turf he says I'm not
saying that I don't think trans women
are women it's like well hold on right
like you know exactly if you take both
of those literally right those those two
those two don't go together right but of
course that's not how Comedy Works
that's like thinking that like somebody
who writes a novel that like every
sentence of the novel is like what they
actually personally think of is is true
but I I think and I've got to think that
a lot of people who write articles like
this
must understand that on some level right
that they that like this is not how
Comedy Works but I think that
you know sometimes it's like bad faith
or you know they're just being dishonest
definitely some of that but like also I
think that
like sometimes if you get this invested
in like making these like moral
indictments of people over these
cultural War battles then you're just
not even pausing to think about that
like you're just like trying to find
evidence like you're just like like
sifting through it to like find like
it's like uh you know Freddie Deborah
the commentator no okay so Freddie
Deboer is a is a writer he wrote a
really good book uh about the education
system called culture smart and he has
this essay from a few years ago called
planet of cops uh where he says that it
seems to him that like increasingly
everybody you know in the culture is is
a is a cop now right what he means by
that and you know he develops the
metaphor he says things like you know oh
there's the new movie that people are
getting excited about you know well give
me you know give me two hours and 500
Words and I'll find you your indictments
right you know that it's it's like it's
sort of constantly sifting through
things to like find evidence that people
have have committed some kind of sin or
or um or infraction and and I think that
like that's how people are approaching
that like when they wrote These articles
you know about you know how oh my god
did you know that Dave Chappelle said
that he was on team Turf you know in
that special
like look there's a mission right you
know you gotta you gotta get those
indictments right so you just have to
sort through all all of it until you can
find something that you know that looks
like a a Smoking Gun of of evidence and
and I think that it's like it's a
obviously it's a terrible way to write
about anything but I think what what's
interesting to me about the example of
Comedy is that it's sort of the most
absurd possible application of of doing
that because I mean just just to be like
simplistic about it for a second right
like if you're saying something in a
stand-up special like generally speaking
not every sentence but like you're
saying it because you think it's funny
right that that's which is just a
different thing from saying something
because like oh you know here is exactly
what I think right you know it's like
the example that we were talking about
before the podcast which I'm not gonna
do because it's actually in my act now
that someone put a quote that I said
well what a piece of [ __ ] on I'm like
hey you got to put the whole quote
because there's like a lot more to that
and it's clearly joking but it's that
thing that they do is also because
someone is getting a disproportionate
and exorbitant amount of attention and
when someone is like a Dave Chappelle or
myself who's got a disproportionate of
attention there's so many people that
want to look at that and go flaws holes
puppet kegs throw rocks like and it's a
normal thing to have this sort of uh
reaction yeah to someone who you feel
either their take on things isn't valid
or it's not this it doesn't align with
your own or you there's a reason why
you're more real morally Superior to
them because your position is better you
know yeah no I think there I think
there's a lot of that you know and and
it's also I mean it kind of goes back to
where we're saying earlier about the uh
the you know BLM protests and the
aftermath and all that stuff like if you
get somebody like if
um I mean obviously in a case it's high
profile it's like Dave Chappelle like
Netflix isn't going to dump him because
like why would they do that like that
would just be putting like a lot of
money on the uh well not only that but
there's no reason to right here's the
thing it's like if Dave Chappelle was
saying all trans people would die it
should die and you know we they're not
human okay yeah get rid of them right
everybody would agree to that like you
shouldn't put that on your network but
you cannot look at any of the things
that he said and rationalize any of
these accusations that people have
towards them he is not that guy he is a
lovely guy if you meet him he was one of
the kindest nicest sweetest guys that's
who he really is and it's really
striking too because if you remember
when all this was going on there was
like a week of the news that was all
about how there's gonna be this huge
walkout of trans employees at Netflix
remember this yeah they took it like a
lunch break it was like five of them
yeah there were like five people and
it's not even clear that they all worked
at Netflix most of them didn't and then
the one of them that was there they
found a whole bunch of racist [ __ ] that
she had put on Twitter and they're like
hey and then not even jokes just like
racist stuff it's like God damn damn it
I don't get what's going on these are
like they're humans humans are flawed
and you know just because they said a
thing that was incorrect doesn't mean
that they're whatever position they have
they can't have a good perspective on
something yeah and what and what kills
me about that example is at that very
moment that that was going on right that
there was this like super hyped up you
know walk out that like got all this
attention there was like you know two
people on their lunch break or whatever
like at the same time there was the John
Deere strike going on and that was that
was you know thousands of people you
know we're we're out on strike for uh to
you know to get better you know wages
and working conditions John Deere the
tractors yeah yep yep the workers I've
heard of that yeah yeah if you go
um if you go I believe you but I mean
yeah I never heard a peep out of that
yeah well that's the thing right so like
you compare the scale of the two things
and then you compare the scale of the
coverage right one of them is jokes yeah
but it's also jokes from the greatest
living comedian that's part of the
problem it's like you and also a guy who
you uh you sort of associate with
left-wing values and Progressive values
and you want them to fall in line and I
think that's part of the blowback is
that you know they they want to shame
him into falling in line with their
ideals and one of the things that he
said like when he we talked about the
special and this is we did a show
together and he did this speech at an
arena and he's like like I am not going
to comply with the way you you know want
me to think and want me to behave that's
not what I'm doing
yeah and and again like what's his
response going to be realistically like
he's he's just gonna
um keep talking [ __ ] that's what he's
gonna do right I mean it's gonna be
funnier and funnier right you know but
like he like the idea that like saying
like he's a terrible person he's a
transphobe like is gonna get him to like
see things more from your perspective in
fact he talks about this one special
right that like he you know he has the
thing about the woman who like followed
him out to the parking lot or whatever
to you know to give him a hard time and
the point is that like all of that like
his reaction was just [ __ ] you right you
know like of course it is right you know
but like then like actually meeting this
trans woman and like having this you
know like like you know like you know
having the interactions that they had
and like having that mean something to
him right like that that
um like that did way more probably to
get him to see things the way that
people were yelling at him wanted him to
see them then like people just like
saying you know that like because if if
you say like if somebody wants to like
shut you down or silence you or like
berate you until you you know you stop
thinking what you think
then I I mean maybe like if somebody's
powerless enough they'll just shut up
because they don't want to deal with it
right you know but like otherwise like
one thing it's not gonna do is to get
them to say okay now I see you're right
right especially like they might say
their perception they might say the
words if they think they have to right
but they're not going to think it right